helping to build a culture of good
mental health for boys and young men of
color
that is the goal of the fifth annual my
brother's keeper conference bianca
holman is live this morning with more on
that hi bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
so in 1965 martin luther king jr said
we must learn to live together as
brothers or we will perish
together as fools and so that is kind of
a perfect quote to really describe the
my brother's keeper alliance
where they're trying to unite young and
old to ensure the next generation
sick is successful and excels so here
we've got some pictures and video
of past years conferences which of
course they met in person but this year
it's going to be virtual
and more than 1 000 people are expected
to attend the focus is on school and
community empowerment strategies and
ways for engaging young men
and boys of color the my brothers keeper
alliance was actually started by former
president barack obama in 2015 to make
sure all youth can reach their full
potential
sheena judy mitchell tells us that black
teen boys are disproportionately
students that are expelled or suspended
from school
so she says this conference shares ways
that adults can better understand
and serve boys of color we want there to
be equity in education
for our kids of color we want there to
be equity in the judicial system
we want there to be equity um
socially as well when our young boys of
color are walking down the street we
don't want them
stereotyped because they're wearing a
hood
so this virtual program is today and
tomorrow from 8 a.m to noon you can
still register on the las vegas city
website some notable presenters include
jay barnett a former professional
football player turned family therapist
dr roberto padilla a new york state
superintendent of the year
and calvin mackey who is an author and
international speaker
and again this conference is free so if
you work with
boys and young men of color you're
definitely encouraged to attend so you
don't necessarily have to be a teacher
but you can be a coach a barber a
counselor and what have you and register
for that conference which is today and
tomorrow
reporting live from martin luther king
boulevard in kerry avenue bianca holman
8 news now thank you very much bianca
very important program